we cover the net because that's when the  crazy stuff happens everybody's gonna be  heading here so we need to get big quick  [Applause]  Wow if there's people in that they're  done I film people's misery I'm there  the worst time in their lives we  document very bad things  my brother film kiddies playing with  each other all right that's not what  people want to see that's not what self  if it is a hit and run now we got a  story I don't normally talk to the  victims of incidents but you should be  dead right now  when you see news I see the dollar signs  I don't want to waste my time out here  if I hit record I wanted on TV  competitions a big deal the television  stations are not gonna buy everyone's  footage there's one story that will be  the top news in the morning so it's a  nod and get it the reason that people  slow down and stare at crashes is kind  of the reason that I have a job  you